au
[Musique]
revoir les enfants bougent
patron je me dépêche de descendre car ce
soir je vais raconter une très jolie
histoire à l'eau de petits hommes oui
vas-y vite le north ma petite jeune
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
pouces mois et sa menace agitée le
raconte une histoire oui là je me pose
écoutez forte attentivement car c'est
une histoire très ancienne
et très intéressant a dit qu
il ya très longtemps dans un pays qu'on
appelle la hollande ou encore pub à
minima parce que la terre ait pu basque
la mère qui la borde et cette terre est
protégé par des grands murs qu'on
appelle inning en a déjà fait donc il ya
très longtemps dans un petit village au
bord de la mer viven un petit garçon qui
avait huit ans il habitait avec ses
parents
il était très gentil utre servian
on s' est ce jour là c'était ça fun et
on était très content car sa maman avait
fait des crèmes des peintres a commencé
les fleurs au pays bras on demandera
meliani et comme il était très gentil
après le tenue il a apporté quelques
crêpes un pauvre vieil homme malade en
rentrant chez lui hans entendit un
curieux bruits
c'est sûrement la digue se dit il et on
ce semi a cherché d'où venait ce bruit
et bien vite il trouva intrus dans la
digue un tout petit trou par lequel
l'eau de la mer couler qu'est ce qu'il a
fait en ce compris qu'ils devaient faire
quelque chose sinon le trou s'agrandit
ray et la mer inonderait très vite tout
le pays alors il mit tout simplement son
doigt dans le trou hello s'arrêta de
couler
il s'est mis à crier au secours les
personnes ne l'entendît décourager
oui il avait froid il avait peur mais il
gardait son doigt dans le trou de la
digue il restera ainsi toute la nuit
fidèle à son poste ses parents le
retrouvèrent au petit matin
transis de froid
tous les gens du pays qu'on solidaire la
dic et firent une grande fête en
l'honneur du petit ranch qui avait sauvé
son pays d'une catastrophe
et voilà les enfants mon histoire est
terminée
vous l'avez mes amis merci et bien à
présent d'aller au lit
polémique ne lance bonne nuit les
enfants
fait pour eux
[Musique]
il en connaît de belles histoires notre
nounours des histoires de tous les bus
du monde patron allons en route fidèles
compagnons auront donné des enfants dob
[Musique]
oh